Jeffrey welcome to the show tell us a
bit about today's game um you tried but
unfortunately you weren't able to break
through your opponent's very strong and
resilient
defense yeah thank you for inviting me
um today was a bit dry I wasn't
expecting this uh Bishop B4 check lying
in the Catland and I think he got what
he wanted um out of the opening probably
after Queen B6 I should have played C5
just to stop this uh D take C4 in the
game but um yeah the one I chose wasn't
too problematic for him and he was able
to equalize relatively easily absolutely
and yesterday uh uh it was a difficult
game obviously against Fabiano with the
white pieces unfortunately you fell for
those complications and in the end game
maybe you were close to a drop but from
a practical perspective with so little
time on the clock it wasn't easy what
were the adjustments that you made after
yesterday's
game yeah I think the main problem about
yesterday's game was just my time
management I played way too slowly uh
after Mo 40 yeah and also
before um so yeah today I tried to play
faster uh unfortunately Andrew was very
solid so it didn't really work to
Perfection uh today as well but I'll
keep trying still many games to be
played and tomorrow you get a
well-deserved rest day guys any
questions for Jeffrey not for me Jeffrey
just uh enjoy your rest day and we'll
see you uh on
Tuesday thank you I wanted to point out
uh boldly point out